so that you deceitful what functions are
my machines what functions are my
business
sexy dot which is short for what sexual
call what was page over here is shocking
changes second short for secant so it's
a circle work so what I need you to do
now on your equator we give the turtle
root that property circular a bit let's
just leave it on your final unit segment
I want you to read role what we have a
diagram with one difference seeing how
here I've got the the blue of the ribbon
because I'm highlighting that what
Aeneid that were close this time I want
you thought everything that's on this
diagram except seen is likely destroyed
in black because there won't be the
focus on this last diagram okay we're
going to add some positive on to it so I
still need my little appease my son I
might draw my tangent
okay so we're still on the unit circle
yes Olli exactly but now we're going to
get we're SEC and perfect colorful and I
wonder if by going to this person
designer have some guesses as to where
it might be okay here's the first thing
I'm going to know when we were doing
this construction over here we noticed
so if there is here it also ends up over
here it has to be because of this pair
of run into triangles that you've got in
fact you've also got similar triangle
heart okay so I'm going to add the
Athena this is the ones by definition
measures on the x axis positive sign off
words any comment there I'm going to
replace this Peter over here that one of
it okay now help me out here
something ugly I wonder if you can work
out in this triangle right or in this
set of triangles can you work out what
this length over here is that vertical
length how would you go about finding it
represent alternatively this length over
here on this bottom triangle this big
one how would you go about working up
what's that look for
so there are a lot of something there's
something there's a lot of my tiger
perches in 70 different games okay it's
a question of where am I going to get
best what your name oh it looks really
good to position 10 it again are we less
computation addition of what but if you
were to look at trying to include not
the right exercise yes you can you can
do any split in your life however I will
point out even though it like you get
the absolute this triangle in order to
do some stuff here but you can work out
these links that I've just mentioned
without any splitting it'll let me help
you let's have a look at this guy down
the bottom here so it's going to put a
question mark on this length from the
origin or wherever okay what it look
like but it would lie flat and it would
be a random pencil case
during on this yeah I'll do how look I'm
going to approach this in a very similar
way to how I approach these guys sure
these so sitting in this triangle is
bigger than one I know an egg like here
and then this two sides here that are
related to this angle
don't forget like we noticed before the
tangent and the radius R perpendicular
to right angles so if I look at the
exercise what are they in relation
through this video oh isn't this guy
over here adjacent that's adjacent
visitor and this one is opposite the
right angle so that makes a hypotenuse
right so therefore I could write in that
triangle that causes fear that's
adjacent over happened
isn't it Oh Jason over hypotenuse so
just like ideas over India I'm just
going to take reciprocals of both sides
what's the reciprocal of clogging up
it's set we justified it as that but do
you see why it is this size down here
that is set because it's mark attention
it doesn't just touch the circle
it cuts straight through the circle
that's what our section is that what a
secant does it cuts straight through
right like an inter section is two
things that cut across each other like a
arm if there's a printer woman giving
birth or she has a c-section it's a cut
across to be able to live the baby
let's see can't divide the crosses
so that that's sexier and what I want
you to learn is just like sign with
office popular better and this table is
opposite set our set is also opposite
feet up be is there so now can you tell
me where Cusack will be which triangle
do I need to put the complement of
theory in the V triangle down it yeah
that's the common setup isn't it it must
be because there's be no there's 90 so
that must be the continent we say
Cosette cosecant opposite this guy all
the way over here
yes because it has to be office as a
compliment right so this kind of video
is Cosette
Xena
[Music]